she's headed. Next that's the
planning effect from fidelity. A
new campaign ad out today from a
super pac that wants Florida
governor Ron Desantis to run for
president made its national
debut this morning. Let's take a
look. Donald Trump has been
attacked by a democratic
prosecutor in New York. So why
is he spending millions
attacking the Republican
governor of Florida trump's
stealing pages from the Biden
Pelosi playbook, repeating lies
about social security should
fight Democrats not lie about
governor Desantis. What happened
to Donald Trump? Joining us to
talk about this. Al Franken,
former U. S senator and Scott
Jennings, senior political
commentator and former special
assistant to president George W.
Bush Al. It was only a matter of
time before these two started
going after each other, and they
seem to be doing that quite a
bit. Now. Any thoughts on who
comes out on top? Well right now
because of the indictment, a lot
of special Maga Republicans, but
a lot of Republicans have come
yeah, to support uh, president
trump and Desantis has gone down
. Ah that's on the first
indictment. I don't know if that
will be the same on the fourth
indictment. The thing about this
ad I noticed is this kind of
defensive. It's not him talking
about anything he wants to do.
It's about ah social security
and of course, Republicans have
been all over the place on
cutting this Rick Scott when he
headed this Republican senate
campaign committee in the last
cycle, said they were going to
make cuts in social security and
medicare. Uh Scalise and
Mccarthy of both talked about
that. Then they've kind of
reversed themselves. And you had
that moment in the state of the
union speech where president
Biden called him on it, and they
said, you lie, and of course, he
wasn't lying. And ah, so ah,
this is seems to be a very
defensive start to Desantis
campaign. And Scott. I mean,
what do you think? Does this
help Democrats that have trump
and Desantis going at each other
gives Joe Biden president Biden
a little more time to announce.
Essentially, you can postpone
that and let these guys duke it
out. Well look, it's a primary
and just like the Democrats in
2020, I think we can expect
these Republicans to go after
each other a little bit. Donald
Trump's never been a shrinking
violet when it comes to lobbying
attacks, and I don't think
Desantis is going to be either.
The real strategic challenge for
Desantis here is that he's
fighting off trump, who's been
attacking him, but he's also got
the other problem of having to
consolidate the non trump lane
of this primary. So the
scientists is by far on top of
that lane, but he still has a
bunch of other people out there
who are also trying to bring him
down, so he's really kind of
fighting a two front war. He's
certainly at the top of one side
of it. But fighting off Donald
Trump while you're trying to do
that is no easy task. I thought
this ad was good. I thought it
helped reframe some of the
attacks and push back against
trump. But he's gonna have to
keep doing that because trump
will be relentless and what he
does to Desantis here. I'm
afraid and our I mean, we have
another mass shooting in
America. This time, it's an
Alabama 15 teens shot, four dead
associated press and R, or C
poll last summer showed that 71%
of respondents say us gun laws
should be stricter. Stricter um
Al, I know you have some strong
thoughts on this. You've
proposed an assault weapon.
Buyback um, what do you think? I
mean, how much longer can the
country wait? Before getting
really serious on this issue
weapons ban. I voted for an
assault weapons ban. And I think
that Republicans are on the
wrong side of this issue now on
the wrong side of a couple
issues this was, uh, guns was
kind of a single voter issue at
one time, you know, pro gun
people Republicans that was
their issue, and then they were
single issue. Republicans on
abortion. And they wanted row
and then, and Democrats weren't
single issue on it. But now they
are. And you saw that Wisconsin
because, once, uh, one stops
happened. Ah what's and lots of
young people lots of, uh, older
women, lots of even Republicans
. Now this is an issue for them
. And you saw again. You saw
this and Wisconsin. There's a
big, I think Republicans are in
trouble on both of these issues.
Scott. What do you think? I
mean, this latest mass shooting
happened after and NRA
convention in Indianapolis,
where you saw several of the
major Republican contenders. All
giving speeches are Republicans.
Out of touch on this. Well first
of all, congress did pass some
legislation in a bipartisan way
last year, so I think the
congress at this point it's gone
as far as it's politically able
to go, so it strikes me that any
legislative action on this is
going to take place at the state
and local level for the
foreseeable future. That's
number one number two. Yeah
there was a shooting in Alabama,
but if I might just take a
personal aside here and say, I'm
sitting in Louisville, there was
a mass shooting in Louisville
last night, we had a bunch of
people gathered in a public park
and gunfire. Two people died.
Several others were injured, and
that comes on the heels of the
other mass shooting at the bank
that we had earlier this week,
which also book ended several
other shootings that happened in
between. So this city, in which
I sit today has been erupting
and gun violence this week, and
the people here are on edge
about it, just like people
everywhere on edge about it. Not
all these crimes are the same.
Not all the criminals are the
same. And maybe not. All the
solutions are the same, but it's
a rising issue in American
politics. Both parties have a
responsibility. I don't have all
the answers, but I get a strong
feeling that congress is going
to be not moving on this and so
at the state level to me, that's
that's where the next set of
actions are going to come. Jim
is it a good idea for all these
Republican contenders to go to
go to an NRA convention? Do you
think Scott well look,
Republicans believe that its
people and criminals that are
the problem Democrats believe
it's guns that are the problem
and I don't think that's going
to change and, um and so the two
parties are fairly well set in
their philosophies about what
the root of this issue is, and
they just really aren't all that
close together on it, so I don't
expect Republicans to stop
campaigning on gun rights. I
mean, being a supporter of the
second amendment has been a
pillar of the Republican party
for quite some time. No, that's
not going to change between now
and the next election. Al last
word to you support the second
amendment. You can support the
second amendment and not be for
these assault weapons that are
really machines of war, and we
were not talking about banning
guns we're talking about in your
talking about states. Scott
making laws well, basically the
supreme court limited what
states can do and in the in
their last session. That. That
was a terrible decision that the
court made and it's going to
limit what states can do. This
is has to be done in congress.
Alright Al Franken, Scott
Jennings. It's an issue that is